if they weren't ignoring yesterday's
Comey report well media hacks were
spinning it so to react to the best and
brightest at other networks let's bring
in John new former Deputy Assistant US
Attorney General John great to see you
as always I want to begin with this from
CNN's legal analyst Ellie Hoenig what I
think we should not lose sight of is
none of this is any sort of vindication
for Donald Trump it doesn't change
anything about what Comey was writing
about in those memos which was Donald
Trump demanding loyalty of him and
Donald Trump trying to get him to shut
down the Flynt investigation those are
still obstruction I believe obstructive
acts and today's finding on Comey has
nothing to do with clearing Trump of
that okay John how did he turn the IG
report would just slam call me sort of
you know charging and recommending
charging him and turning into well
Trump's not vindicated this is law this
is like cuckoo for cocoa puffs stuff
Laura I'm sad to say after I read the IG
report trumped in obstruct justice
Trump freed justice chump freed the
Justice Department of a man a
self-righteous crusader who rejected the
results of our constitutional system and
democracy that was President Trump won
the 2016 election and then he decided
that normal basic rules of the Justice
Department didn't apply to him in his
crusade to stop President Trump and that
basic rule is we don't as Justice
Department or FBI agents willingly and
freely share the results of confidential
investigations with the New York Times
or the press to attack people we don't
like we keep those things confidential
in order to pursue successful
investigations if Jim Comey had been a
normal Justice Department prosecutor or
line FBI agent he would been fired on
the spot for what he did in the IG
requestion is asked and John here's
MSNBC's legal analyst Julia Ainsley's
take for people who have been talking to
Justice Department employees and former
Justice Department employees today they
say Horowitz completely misses the
context here and it's like if you were
to charge him and if he referred it to
the Justice Department who declined to
charge him but it's like punishing
someone for speeding on their way to put
out a fire John
speeding taken is that analogous I think
that's almost ridiculous this is a guy
who should never have been FBI director
look at what he did he put the country
through two years of an investigation we
it took two years of Bob Muller to find
out that the whole thing was groundless
and Jim Comey because he didn't like
Donald Trump broke all the rules it's
not just like speeding these are the
basic rules that govern the Justice
Department and what did we get in
exchange two years of wasted time and
effort not just the cost of the Muller
report to our whole political system
which delayed the workings of a
democratically elected president to get
on with his agenda that has been a
disaster for the country John here is
the host of hardhead hardball prompters
out Chris Matthews the British
government leak stuff to Churchill put
it out about the military buildup by the
Germans you know sometimes there's a
justifiable cause here Churchill Hitler
John I can't even tell what he's talking
about this is again this I think the
real problem here was Jim Comey not
Donald Trump as you said Laura it's
really incredible this IG report is a
damning indictment of someone who's an
FBI director someone who committed many
of the abuses that Jagger Hoover did
against Martin Luther King this was
against spreading information from FBI
files to damage and harm people when he
wasn't going to prosecute him and this
is a guy
I'm afraid who should never have been
FBI I got to say actually I have to
realize I do report one of the most
important things Donald Trump ever did
one of the best things he did for the
country was actually to fired fired Jim
Comey John great insights as always
thanks so much